[Music]
that was something and even now if
you're watching on nbcsn you saw the
double doink when the ball comes off of
the crossbar i still think it goes the
right way it was like an optical
illusion right even when i see it now
until i see the ball break the front of
the the crossbar and clearly not be good
it's still oh and sorry bears fans but
that was that that was a weird outcome a
painful outcome a special season comes
crashing down what if wednesday what if
that optical illusion wasn't an illusion
what if it was real what if the ball did
go the right way and the bears advance
past the eagles and get to the division
around the playoffs chris what to get
look into your crystal ball what would
have happened next i mean it's an
interesting conversation because this is
right where you go okay for what if
wednesday you go oh okay now the the
divisional round has been flipped upside
down chicago's gonna go play the rams in
la you mean the team that they just
dominated a few weeks before in chicago
and i remember at the time i said i
don't care where the rams play the bears
i don't care if it's on mars the moon
chicago la that was going to be a tough
matchup for them i was kind of saying
that at the time the bears matched up
really well with the los angeles rams
who were a team that wasn't going into
the playoffs like flying high and
feeling great about the way they played
in general so i look at that and go oh i
don't like that matchup for the rams i
think the bears would have won that one
and then the bears are in the nfc
championship game then you go to the
other ripple effect of the saints and
the cowboys mike same story you know
late november was that early december i
don't know cowboy saints playing on
thursday night cowboys physically kind
of whooped the new orleans saints in
that game yes it was close on the
scoreboard but i think it was a a little
bit more of a gap than the score would
lead you to believe in that game as far
as the way it was played and i don't
necessarily love the way the saints
matched up against the cowboys but i
would still take the saints at home
against dallas on that one so i think we
would have a bears saints nfc
championship game you like where i'm
going here yet anything you want to
throw in yeah no no i i kind of like
that because i know the saints were very
interested in getting another crack at
the cowboys and getting them in new
orleans and look i i don't know would
the saints have been able to pull it off
i tend to agree with you that the saints
would have won that game yeah and it
would have been bears saints which means
we wouldn't be spending so much time now
talking about replay review of past
interference because if ram saints
doesn't happen and there was another
scenario where we went down this rabbit
hole where ram saints doesn't happen we
don't have the nikkel roby coleman tommy
lee lewis wipe out at the end of
regulation of course there may have been
something else screwy that would have
happened under this other scenario but i
think you're right
bears have a chance to beat the rams in
la i'm not as confident though as you
are because i remember the weather
seemed to be a factor tonight the bears
beat the rams jared goff the california
kid playing in the cold i don't think he
likes playing in the cold and i think it
would have been different also there
would have been that same element of
getting even yes with the bears just
like the saints would have had with the
cowboy so you know i i hate to say it
but i have a feeling yeah it would have
been the same outcome it would have been
ram saints in the nfc championship game
so i'm gonna disagree with you on the
bears beating the rams in l.a okay
that's okay that's fine i i'm no no
problem there i think ultimately you
know i do i think the bears would pull
it off i think the rams would give a
better showing uh certainly i mean i
know the the first matchup i believe
ended up 1510 right in in the bears
favor or something right along those
lines um but you know i just didn't i
didn't love that match up with the rams
and i think what some of the things the
patriots did on the in the super bowl uh
against the rams they stole some of
those defenses and what they played from
the chicago bears game plan you know
schematically uh the interior defensive
line for the bears defense versus that
rams interior line that we saw struggled
with fletcher cox and akeem hicks early
in the year or earlier in those matchups
so that was that would be an issue for
me but i think ultimately what i would
like to go with what if wednesday is the
bears win that game they go to new
orleans and i think new orleans can beat
chicago i think new orleans matched up
better with chicago than the rams did
they win that football game and we have
a patriots saints super bowl there to
where i go oh i don't know who wins that
game because i sit there look i have a
hard time thinking that the patriots
were going to shut down the drew brees
and sean payton with two weeks of
preparation and shut them down to three
points so uh i think that could have
been a great super bowl matchup
hey another reality if that kick goes
through and the bears advance past the
eagles i think eagles fans have a little
less angst moving forward yes with
carson wentz instead of nick falls
because i'm i'm telling you there are
going to be eagles fans they're just
kind of quietly watching what foles does
in jacksonville hoping that that falls
doesn't prove them wrong in moving on
from him and keeping carson wins and
also whether to what extent went stays
healthy is going to be part of that
equation but i think if that kick is
good it's less of a concern because it
was way too close to lightning in a
bottle times two for the eagles by
having that crack at the saints and
almost beating the saints and almost
getting back to the nfc championship
game you wipe them out in the wild card
round you've got less of that that uh
that ongoing anxiety for eagles fans
about nick foles performance yeah i
agree i i wanted to mention that but
yeah you're right i think they're more
comfortable with where they are right
now yes certainly if they don't win that
game and it doesn't end the way it does
in new orleans that way other question
for you cody cody parkey
okay is he on the team still there you
know did he still make it or did he do
enough damage to the regular season
where it double doink or not it didn't
really matter
yeah you know what it would have been
determined by what he does with his
kicks in the next game yeah i mean you
know that i don't want to punt there no
pun intended but i think that he would
have had a chance to redeem himself by
making some kicks that don't hit the
upright or the crossbar
or both as the case may be so
hey you know what maybe they wish they
had cody park he's still after
the revolving door of whatever it is the
bears are trying to do
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports